johnny depp gives surprise performance
at jeff beck concert
[Music]
johnny depp hits the stage just days
after closing arguments for his ongoing
defamation trial against his ex-wife
amber hurt
[Music]
johnny a notable guitarist apart from
his film career made a surprise
appearance sunday night at a jeff beck
concert in england he joined jeff on
stage to perform their 2020
collaboration isolation a remake of john
lennon's 1970 hit the two also performed
a cover of marvin gaye's what's going on
in jimi hendrix's little wing johnny
depp gives surprise performance at jeff
beck concert
[Music]
when i was a kid all i dreamed about was
becoming a famous rock star or you know
this i don't know
this great musician johnny's performance
comes only two days after lawyers
delivered closing arguments in his 50
million dollar defamation case against
his ex-wife think about every piece of
evidence that you've heard over the last
six weeks about his abuse about their
relationship
none of that is in the article
none of it
we all know that it would be a very
different article if she had written
about what she suffered that she's told
you about over the last six weeks the
trial kicked off on april 11 johnny is
suing amber for defamation related to
her 2018 op-ed published in the
washington post where she alleges she
was a victim of domestic violence you
only sued the author
of this article amber heard correct
which seems she was the one making the
statements yes i
had the opportunity to
fight back but amber is counter-suing
for defamation claiming that public
statements made by johnny's lawyer adam
waldman called her allegations fake
halted her career causing her to lose
millions what if any range are the
losses you are estimating for amber
heard but for the deb waldman statements
it's over time right so let's just say a
minimum of five years that we're going
to talk about these losses and it could
be more but at minimum if you look at
the
film the television
and the endorsement contracts
it's very likely that miss heard should
have earned between 45 and 50 million
dollars over that time period and after
six weeks both sides rested their cases
today
on may 27
2022
exactly six years later
we ask you to give mr depp his life back
by telling the world that mr deaf is not
the abuser misheard said he is
and hold ms heard accountable for her
life you can't restore his reputation
you can't give him anything she finally
has said enough
enough
and we're asking you to finally
hold this man responsible he has never
accepted responsibility for anything in
his life and now it's in the
seven-person jury's hands deliberations
continue this week
[Music]